the truth about yuji's parents in jujutu
Kaizen is terrifying yuji's father Jin
was in love with a woman named kauri and
he wanted to have a family with her
unfortunately at some point she died but
Jin simply couldn't give up on kauri and
his dream of having a family with her so
he seems to have accepted some sort of
deal with the devil or rather a deal
with the evil sorcerer kenjaku kenjaku
was able to bring cowdy back to life by
possessing her body and then cowdy and
jyn produced a child Yuji but while Yuji
biologically belongs to Jin and kauri
when Yuji was conceived kauri's body was
being controlled By kanjaku Yuji is
actually a human experiment and his
mother was a body snatching evil
sorcerer if you want to know more about
this sorcerer and his power check out my
full video link in the description and
in the pinned comment